este es otro de los módulos esto es
trigonometría esto es translación y
reflexión de funciones
tenemos actualmente 90 de estos pueden
ir al sitio es completamente gratis no
intentamos vender nada
la idea general es que todo entre dentro
de este mapa de conocimiento el nodo
superior representa sumas de un dígito
11 igual 2
el paradigma es una vez que resuelves 10
seguidos avanzas y eso te motiva a
llegar a módulos más avanzados si
continuamos avanzando en el mapa vemos
aritmética más avanzada
continuamos si tenemos pre álgebra y
principios de álgebra más abajo tenemos
álgebra 12 y un poco de pre cálculo
la idea es que podamos enseñar todo
bueno todo lo que se puede enseñar con
este marco
así que se pueden imaginar estamos
trabajando en esto en este mapa tenemos
lógica programación
gramática genética y todo basándonos en
que si tienes esto y aquello estás listo
para este siguiente concepto
esto puede funcionar bien para un
estudiante por su cuenta pero los animo
a que lo hagan con sus hijos pero
también a que lo hagan ustedes cambiar a
lo que platican durante la cena lo que
queremos hacer es usar la conclusión
natural de lo que hacen los maestros de
quienes hablaba
lo que les muestro aquí son datos de un
programa piloto en el distrito escolar
de los altos tomaron dos grupos de
quinto año y dos grupos de séptimo y
tomaron sus materias de matemáticas
estos niños no están usando libros de
texto no están teniendo clases
universales están trabajando con khan
academy y con el software en la mitad de
sus materias de matemáticas y quiero
dejar esto claro no vemos esto como una
educación completa de matemáticas lo que
hacemos y lo que está ocurriendo en los
saltos es liberar el tiempo hacemos el
trabajo pesado nos aseguramos de que
sepas cómo resolver un sistema y
liberamos tiempo para las simulaciones
para los juegos para armar el robot
para la estimación de la altura de esa
colina con la longitud de su sombra el
paradigma es el maestro acude todos los
días cada quien trabaja a su ritmo estos
son datos reales de los saltos cada fila
es un estudiante cada columna es un
concepto
verde indica que el estudiante ya lo
domina azul indica que está trabajando
en el rojo significa que está atorado y
lo que el maestro hace es literalmente
dice déjenme intervenir con el
estudiante en rojo o mejor aún dejen que
uno de los niños en verde sean mi
primera línea de ataque y ayuden a su
compañero
ahora
yo vengo de una realidad muy centrada en
datos así que no queremos que el maestro
intervenga y haga preguntas tediosas
como qué es lo que sabes o qué es lo que
no sabes así que nuestro paradigma es
armar al maestro con tantos datos como
sea posible datos con los que en
cualquier otro campo se cuentan finanzas
mercadotecnia manufactura con los que el
maestro realmente pueda diagnosticar qué
puede hacer para que puedan hacer su
interacción tan productiva ahora el
maestro sabe exactamente en qué ha
estado el alumno cuánto tiempo ha
trabajado al día qué vídeos ha visto en
qué momento pausa los vídeos en donde
dejó de ver el vídeo qué ejercicios ha
hecho en qué han estado enfocados el
círculo exterior muestra en qué
ejercicios se han enfocado el interior
muestra en qué vídeos se han enfocado y
los datos son muy grano lares así que es
posible ver exactamente qué ejercicio se
ha hecho bien o mal rojo es mal azul es
bien la barra más a la izquierda es el
primer problema que intentó este vio el
vídeo justo ahí y pueden ver que
eventualmente pudo contestar 10 seguidas
casi puedes verlos aprender la altura es
cuánto tiempo les tomo
cuando hablas de aprendizaje a tu ritmo
todo el mundo lo entiende velocidad de
aprendizaje diferenciado
pero es algo increíble lo que ocurre
cuando lo ves en la clase toda vez que
hemos hecho esto en todas las clases una
y otra vez si dedicamos cinco días a
esto
hay un grupo de niños que avanzan muy
rápido y otro que es más lento en un
modelo tradicional dirían estos son los
alumnos listos estos son los malos los
lentos tal vez deberíamos ponerlos en
grupos separados pero cuando los dejas
trabajar a su ritmo
vemos una y otra vez que hay estudiantes
a los que les toma un poco más un
concepto u otro
pero una vez que pueden con el concepto
se colocan en la primera posición y los
mismos niños que pensabas que eran
lentos hace seis semanas ahora piensas
que son muy inteligentes lo hemos visto
una y otra vez y te hace preguntarte
cuántas veces que hemos sido etiquetados
positivamente
ha sido realmente solo una coincidencia
de tiempo
tan valioso como esto es en el distrito
de los altos de nuestro objetivo es usar
la tecnología
para humanizar no solo los saltos sino a
una escuela global a la educación y esto
nos trae un punto importante muchos de
los esfuerzos en humanizar el salón de
clase
se centran en el número de alumnos por
cada profesor desde nuestra perspectiva
la métrica relevante debe ser tiempo
valioso humano con el profesor por
alumno en el modelo tradicional el
profesor dedica la mayor parte de su
tiempo en dar clase calificar exámenes
tal vez solo cerca el 5% de su tiempo lo
ocupa trabajando con sus alumnos ahora
es ciento por ciento de su tiempo así
que otra vez usando la tecnología se
humaniza el salón de clase por un factor
de 5 o 10
y siendo tan valioso como lo es en los
saltos imaginen lo que pueden hacer por
un adulto mayor a quien le avergüenza
regresar a aprender algo que debió
aprender antes imaginen lo que haría por
un niño en calcuta que tiene que ayudar
a su familia durante el día
y por esta razón falta a la escuela
ahora el pueblo él puede dedicarle dos
horas al día y compensar el tiempo
perdido incluso avanzar más sin sentirse
avergonzado por lo que sabe o no
imaginen ahora lo que pasa cuando los
alumnos se ayudan mutuamente en el salón
de clases
esto es un solo sistema no hay razón por
la cual no puedas tener esa ayuda mutua
más allá de ese salón de clases
imaginen lo que ocurre si ese niño en
calcuta puede ahora ayudar a tu hijo o
tu hijo puede ayudar a ese niño en
calcuta
y lo que vemos emergiendo de esta noción
de un salón de clases mundial global
eso es esencialmente lo que queremos
construir gracias
he visto algunas cosas que han hecho en
el sistema relacionados con motivación y
retroalimentación
muchos de energía medallas cuéntame lo
que han pensado ahí
así tenemos un increíble equipo y quiero
dejar esto claro ya no soy solo yo aún
hago los vídeos pero tenemos un equipo
rock star desarrollando el software
hemos puesto un montón de mecánicas de
juegos en donde obtienes medallas
existen tableros de liderazgo por áreas
ha sido muy interesante incluso con las
palabras que usamos o por los puntos que
damos vemos decenas de miles
decenas de miles de alumnos de quinto
sexto años yendo de un lado a otro
dependiendo de qué premio les demos
y la colaboración que has hecho con los
saltos cómo ocurrió
fue algo loco yo no esperaba que lo
usaran en los salones de clase pero
alguien de la dirección vino y
y fue algo loco me pregunto qué harías
si te diéramos un cheque en blanco con
la clase y dije bueno ya sabes
estudiantes aprendiendo a su propio
ritmo un tablero de datos y él dijo
bueno esto es algo radical tenemos que
pensarlo
y el resto del equipo y yo pensamos no
van a querer hacerlo
pero literalmente al día siguiente me
dijeron puedes comenzar en dos semanas
así que son matemáticas de quinto grado
son dos grupos de quinto grado y dos
grupos de séptimo grado lo están
haciendo a nivel de distrito lo que les
gusta mucho es que pueden seguir a estos
niños no es sólo algo en la escuela
pudimos ver niños en navidad siendo esto
podemos ver todo los pueden seguir
mientras avanzan por el distrito entero
mientras van de un maestro a otro
tenemos esta continuidad de datos a
nivel de distrito
así que algunas de las vistas que
observamos son para que el maestro vea
qué ocurre con estos niños
han tenido retroalimentación acerca de
ellas
claro de hecho algunas fueron diseñadas
por los maestros también hicimos algunas
para los alumnos
pero tenemos iteraciones de diseño
constantes con los maestros en donde nos
dicen esto está bien pero
tengo la impresión de que muchos alumnos
solo están saltando y no se enfocan en
un tema
así que hicimos ese diagrama todo ha
sido guiado por los profesores ha sido
muy loco está listo para usarse crees
que las escuelas deban probarlo el
próximo año
si está listo tenemos a un millón de
personas en el sitio ya podemos aguantar
un poco más
está
no hay razón por la que no pueda usarse
en cada salón de clase de américa mañana
la visión de las tutorías la idea es si
estoy confundido con un tema justo en la
interfaz de usuario
se pueden encontrar voluntarios se puede
ver su reputación y agendar una
conferencia con ellos
absolutamente y esto es algo que les
recomiendo a todos aquí pueden entrar en
este momento
y volverse tutor de sus hijos sus
sobrinos sus primos o tal vez algunos
del club de niños y niñas
pueden volverse un tutor inmediatamente
y si está todo ahí
bueno es increíble creo que acabamos de
ver un pequeño adelanto del futuro de la
educación gracias gracias a usted